i just want to speak to decluttering
when it comes to your life in the
kitchen
yes what do i do rachel what do i do
perfectly i have done this i have lived
this
twice this year when i started working
from home in march
i realized that my pantry had gotten out
of control
and if i was going to turn it into a
useful production kitchen for myself and
my family
i had to clean house you have to go
through everything
top to bottom marie would agree marie
kondo would agree with this
top to bottom read your expiration dates
clean out your fridge your freezer
your shelves your spices get rid of
anything that's out of date and
reorganize what do you really need
and if you have 10 of one thing or pots
and pans that you don't use anymore
give them to your local food banks and
food shelters they need help more
more than any time that i can think of
in my adult life now so
they take excess canned food they take
excess
kitchen product uh or utensils and pots
and pans
that you're kind of streamlining if you
can give to your neighbor
do that but really go perfect and make a
list
of what you keep in your freezer what
you have on hand so you don't over
buy or rebuy and don't waste and
clean out that fridge once a week top to
bottom
and keep a pantry list running of
staples
so every time i run out of dried beans
or canned beans or tomatoes
staples for my family and my lifestyle
i literally put it on the pantry list as
a restock that week
and if you keep more control over what
you have on hand you'll waste
less money also process everything the
minute you bring it inside the house
we all do that now with the boxes and
things but you have to do it with your
food too
put it away clean and you'll use more
fruits vegetables
you'll eat a healthier diet if
everything's ready to use
yes not waiting for you to manipulate